I have taken the liberty of arranged
spires for your lab starting bid 1
billion dollars Thank You sunny really
but my father and I have something
slightly more pressing than starting a
business so I'll just take the component
as arranged my buyers don't take no for
an answer so we a that in business
together oh we aren't a business yeah ok
good yes yet no no put that down that's
worth more than you or me yeah
happy the craziest thing just happened
to me these guys are robbing an ATM with
these high tech ok uh no time for ATM
robberies or the thoughtful notes you
leave behind I have moving day to worry
about wait wait you're moving who's
moving don't you watch the news Tony
sold Avengers Tower or relocating to a
new facility upstate where hopefully the
cell service is much more
all right wills up a ten minutes we just
got a load Tony's old Hulkbuster armor
prototype for caps new shield and the
making the make the Thor's magic belt
hey everybody its charlie we need to
talk about sinister six in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I've already done a
couple videos about spider-man far from
home in the characters that we know have
been confirmed or rumored for the film
seeming to set up a Loki version of MCU
sinister six but now that we've had a
chance to see ant-man the wasp it just
seems like the coincidences are stacking
up for them setting up a presence for
Oscorp and larger sinister six things
inside the universe aka Tony selling the
Avengers Tower
so I'll explain what's going on with
that there are also a lot of websites
reporting that a brand new villain has
also joined spider-man far from home
along with the creator of the Spider
Slayer so it just sounds like a lot of
big things are happening in this movie
if you're brand new to the channel we're
doing a weekly infinity war blu-ray
giveaway I'll explain at the end of the
video be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos so you go all the way back to
spider-man homecoming and you learned
that they're selling the Avengers Tower
at that point there were still a number
of plausible theories like maybe they
could be setting up Fantastic Four it
was before all the Disney stuff was
happening so there were that many
possibilities but when the movie
originally came out when they were doing
their interviews of course people were
asking Kevin Feige in any Pascal when
are we gonna see Norman Osborn again
because vulture was the big villain of
that film and they said that they wanted
to try things and characters that they
had not done before and as Michael
Keaton does with the vulture we get to
explore villains that we haven't seen
before and Spidey has an amazing rose
gallery so at some point I think it
might be interesting to to revisit some
of the characters we've seen in films
before but right now we think there are
a lot of new ones that we haven't
haven't played with yet but as far as
I'm concerned I hope we keep making
movies with Marvel and keeping
spider-man where he belongs in another
interview Amy Pascal also said I think
there are certain characters I don't
think there's anything more to say about
them right at this minute
I think we have to try and be fresh with
it now she was talking about homecoming
so obviously she's saying that you know
we just tried to do a version of Green
Goblin a couple different times in a row
so we don't want to go right back to
that well but the way Kevin Feige plays
that game
Thanos style is that you just tease
things early on that become Easter eggs
that you turn into big plot points later
on when you pay them off like Nick Fury
teasing to Iron Man that there are other
superheroes out there you're part of
something bigger couple years down the
road that turns into the big Avengers
franchise so even though they almost got
there during the Andrew Garfield era
they have not done genuine sinister six
team-up in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so even though I don't think the
character Norman Osborn is in spider-man
far from home
I do think that he will ultimately be
behind the masa nations of the sinister
six because somebody has to bankroll all
this tech and that's where that ant-man
scene comes in where you have Sonny
birch saying that he works for a group
of people that don't take no for an
answer in that have a billion dollars to
throw out like it's a lowball offer like
they just have tens of billions of
dollars sitting around to potentially
get in on Hank Pimm's quantum Tech
that's where you get into Oscorp where
you get into people that could rival
Tony Stark's Stark Industries within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as business
competitors which also helps broaden the
Spider Man mythology so that regardless
of what they do with the character in
the future you just have a lot more
possible avenues that you could take his
story so like if in seven or eight years
Tom Horn doesn't want to be the
character anymore
you still have a very broad spider-man
universe within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so like a little while ago I
asked people on Twitter like would you
like to see Norman Osborn become a big
Avengers level villain like you have
real small villains like the vulture who
are real badass like Iron Man said this
is below the Avengers pay grade think
about quantum Tech as a way to bring
that to an Avengers level threat and
that's something that a scorpan Norman
Osborn would want to get their hands on
the big reason why I don't think that
he's in spider-man far from home is is
because they would have probably told us
that they were gonna cast him because it
would be very marketable it would get
people so much more excited about the
film if he were going to be fighting
Green Goblin and for the most part
they've been hyping up Jake Gyllenhaal's
Mysterio is the main villain and we
still haven't heard about him officially
I think that's probably because they
haven't needed to film any scenes with
the actor without his
you really only need to cast actors when
you need them in scenes as themselves
you could put any stunt man in a
Mysterio suit and nobody would know the
difference most of you on the sinister
six video a while ago I did we're like
wow this is a lot of villains I hope
they don't put too many in here so that
is why this new villain that websites
are reporting is joined the film is
molten man is probably not that big of a
character like obviously he doesn't
sound like that big of a deal he might
just be a bit part he might not even
have special powers the reason why all
these websites think that he's in the
film is because they're making toys for
the film based on his character so
people are like why would they make a
toy for a character that's not even in
the film so if you're not sure what's
going on with that they do this all the
time with Marvel movies they'll make the
characters look as comic-book e as
possible to get kids really excited
about buying them even if they don't
wear a costume during the film so molten
man's real name in the comics is mark
racks ttan we might just be seeing that
mark character in real life and he does
not wear any special suit they're also
reporting this Spencer Smythe is a
character and far from home as well the
cool thing about him is that he's the
original creator of the spider-slayers
so it sounds like Mysterio is still
supposed to be the big bad but he's
co-opting the services of other people
like the Tinker in the vulture during
homecoming to help give him tech to do
whatever crimes it is that he's trying
to do around the world whether he's
robbing banks or doing something else
not too close open that as it's the only
thing that can penetrate the black
widows armor we're almost ready so even
though jake gyllenhaal is a huge get for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and he
could totally lead a version of the
sinister six by himself I'm just hoping
that there is somebody behind that that
will try to put the team together like
look all of you hates spider-man why
don't we work together so Marvel's been
laying all these Easter eggs for Oscorp
do you actually want them to pay that
off my worry is is that the lawyers
between Marvel and Sony in that sharing
arrangement will get in the way a really
cool story that they're trying to pay
off so hopefully they'll be able to
integrate more Norman Osborn into the
MCU later on without any big problems
but I do fully expect them to resize
that a sharing arrangement and they'll
announce a third spider-man film
sometime late next year but as far as
I'm concerned I hope we keep making
movies with Marvel and keeping
spider-man where he belongs
quick reminder the spider-man game drops
next week for ps4 what'll happen is is
I'll do a non-spoilery review of that
sometime early next week then maybe some
gameplay on my game channel it's called
Charlie streams there's a link for that
in the description but leave all your
requests in the comments below like I
said there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner when I post
new Marvel but click here for that brand
new venom trailer and click here to
learn all about the Avengers for
reshoots thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]